so you're an investor you're looking for
places to put your money and you keep
hearing about what could be the biggest
IPO of all time
Saudi Aramco the world's biggest share
offering the biggest IPO in history to
be clear the share sale is happening on
the local stock exchange the to dabble
and is mostly aimed at Saudi Arabians
it's on ATMs it's on billboards the
state-owned newspapers are advertising
it banks are offering loans for people
to buy shares in Aramco Aramco isn't
just any old company it's the most
profitable one in the world its desired
valuation even on the low end Dwarfs
corporate giants like Apple and Amazon
but its road to going public has been
long and complicated taking the world's
most profitable company to market has
not been an easy job it's all about the
valuation after years of delay and amid
new security threats posed by rival Iran
Saudi Aramco announcing plans of course
to list on the Tadao so it's a Ramco a
good bet for investors there are a few
things you need to consider first is how
Aramco makes money simply put oil and
that's great when oil markets are strong
but going all-in on one asset in this
case oil means you're exposed to its
value and that value changes a lot in
2018 Aramco turned a bigger profit than
any other company still the company's
third quarter net income this year was
down 30% from the same time last year
that's in part because of lower oil
prices with all of the uncertainty
around the price of oil it's hard to
tell if a Ramco can grow and experts
can't even agree on how much the
company's actually worth a very basic
way to look at a Ram Coast value is
based on how much oil Saudi Arabia has
underground in 2018
the kingdom controlled nearly 18% of the
world's reserves if a Ramco can make a
roughly eight dollar profit on each of
those barrels
give it a two trillion dollar valuation
but Aramco's latest price target falls
three to four hundred billion dollars
short of the two trillion dollar
valuation the crown prince was aiming
for that lower price target acknowledges
some risks Aramco's business faces like
tensions in the Middle East the price of
renewable energy and demand for electric
cars and Aramco's prospectus
acknowledges that climate change could
have a negative impact on its business
the energy market is changing and Aramco
may have to change too in 2018 roughly
34 percent of the world's energy was
fueled by oil but there's only so much
oil to be drilled and the market for
renewable energy is on the rise the
share of renewables in global energy
consumption is expected to grow from 4%
today to 15% by 2040 the oil industry
has been under pressure from regulators
and politicians around the world to help
develop cleaner alternatives to fossil
fuels so a lot of the oil majors
globally have been making investments in
the last couple of years into new energy
businesses and these can be wind farms
it can be electric vehicle charging
stations but at this stage we're not
seeing any big moves by Aramco into
renewable energy while Aramco itself
isn't investing much in renewable energy
the country of Saudi Arabia wants to the
crown prince plans to use some of the
money raised from Aramco's IPO to make
his country less reliant on oil by
investing in things like technology
tourism wind and solar power he can do
that because the Saudi Kingdom
technically owns a Ramco and the crown
prince can potentially do what he wants
with the company as long as the
government controls it that's another
big question among investors even after
an IPO it might be hard to know exactly
where the Saudi government starts and
Aramco ends just look at a ram coast
board six of the 11 members have current
or former ties to the Saudi government
and the government's priorities are
baked into a Ram Coast business plan its
prospectus even says Aramco might do
things for the Saudi Kingdom even if it
doesn't make the most sense financially
the Saudi Kingdom is the shareholder of
Aramco so it has absolutely been in the
driving seat of whether or not this IPO
goes ahead and that has been one of the
reasons that the IPO has been repeatedly
delayed since it was first announced in
2016 the other issue is ESG
environmental social governance issues
these been things that investors have
been growing increasingly concerned
about and there's definitely some issues
around that for Aramco and environment
around human rights in 2018
Jamal khashoggi a journalist who was
critical of the Saudi kingdom's
leadership was murdered by Saudi
operatives while the United Nations and
CIA have implicated the crown prince in
the ordering of the murder the Kingdom
has denied his role after the murder
some investors publicly distanced
themselves from the country by dropping
out of a big Saudi business conference
now the Saudi government's role in a ram
coast future is unclear Aramco is only
putting a small percentage of its
business up for sale so the kingdom will
still own most of the company after the
IPO that doesn't just present an ethical
dilemma for investors
it raises tangible security concerns -
since Aramco could be a target for
countries at odds with Saudi Arabia just
think back to September when a drone
attack briefly wiped out half of a ram
Kozel production Saudi Arabia blamed
Iran for the airstrikes but Iran has
denied its involvement the costs of
recovering from the September attacks
were part of the reason Aramco's net
profits for q3 were down 30 percent from
last year and Aramco's prospectus said
terrorism and armed conflict could have
a significant impact on its business
while it took less than a month for the
company to return to its original
production output the attacks showed
investors that Aramco is facing some
pretty serious security risks even being
the world's largest or the world's most
profitable company doesn't mean it will
necessarily be successful after it goes
public and the IPO isn't expected to be
the big global offering it was initially
pitched as after pressure built up from
international investors to disclose more
information about its business Aramco
decided to gear the IPO mainly towards
Saudi investors a Ramco declined to
comment on a story about its IPO
obstacles and the Saudi government said
the IPO has gone according to plan from
day one so he's a Remco a good bet well
they are guaranteeing a dividend but on
the flip side it is hard to see what the
story for this company will be in future
as we move through the energy transition
away from fossil fuels and into more new
energies
you